So now that we've covered those kind of under-the-hood fundamentals that go into making a project even open in the first place
It's worth going into a little bit more of the kind of gameplay side the kind of fundamental
Lego bricks that go into making the kind of gameplay functionality
So everything really fundamentally leads back to UObject like we'd spoke about before
It's important to bear in mind that when we're talking about just a raw UObject these things have no
Representation in the world. They have no collision. They have no position. They're just data
That data can be updated at runtime. It's not plain old data, but it is just a kind of data object
They have no inbuilt tick functionality. They have no concept of a world that they exist in
They have no way to tick. Tick is Unreal's version of an update function something that runs once per frame
Whenever you're spawning a UObject you have to be provided with some kind of outer if you which is the object it lives within
If you don't provide it with an outer it will default to the transient package
And transient like the UProperty markup means that this object is kind of regarded as temporary and won't be saved
It's important to highlight that UObjects can support networking, but it does require some additional setup
So if you're thinking about data needing to get replicated over a network you can do it through UObject
But it's worth questioning whether or not there might be a better way a more kind of like
Streamlined and easier to implement with the engine way of doing that
UObjects isn't always the first thing you should be thinking of when you when you're thinking about network replication
just to kind of give an example of what a UObject might be in a typical game situation if we have an
example of an explosive barrel
And that explosive barrel will exist in the world
It'll be an actor which we'll get to in a moment, and it will have some components on it
Which we'll also get to in a moment, but maybe
The way we store and this this barrel can explode and the way we store that data about what the explosion is
That might be the kind of thing we do through a UObject so just through some editing magic
I've jumped ahead and kind of created an example of this explosive barrel that we can kind of look at
So just jumping into this explosion data asset
This is what that might look like as a UData asset extends from a UObject so we can see here
And you can see we've got the
Markup, but we need you before because this is we've not we're still in that UObject part of the hierarchy
So this is a data asset and here we've implemented the particle this explosion should use when it fires
The sound effect that it plays and the kind of radius
so this is some example of what a UObject might look like in your game and
Then moving on we have an actor. This is the kind of
Fundamental building block that you see in the level so unlike UObjects these do exist in the level
They can have positions they can have collisions
they can have a visual representation and
It's worth mentioning that whenever you're in an editor a really easy way to tell if something is an actor is if it appears in
This section on the right here the world outliner, and it's not to say a hundred percent of actors displayed here
There are cut one or two that are hidden away
But for the most part of them the folders here anything that is in this list is going to be an actor
That's just kind of a good rule of thumb
So yeah unlike objects where they require a bit of manual setup
It's much easier to get that kind of client server network communication working on an actor
It's set up for that kind of thing. It's set up for RPCs. It's set up for
Variable replication data replication in that way
And the other thing to highlight is that actors can inject their own behavior importantly
That's something that distinguishes unreal from other proprietary software that you may have used
Actors can have their own opinion about how code should work
But they do also implement this component architecture which allows us to bring functionality
In from other places and make it a little bit more portable which we'll get into in a moment
So an explosive an example of an actor might be the X a explosive barrel again note the a
Before the because now we are in the actor element of the hierarchy. So just jumping back into our code
We have our exploding barrel actor
This is just a quick example that I made we can see this
Exploding barrel you has the a in the class definition, but not actually in the file name
Inherits from actor and we can see what an actor might look like
We'll talk about components in a moment, but you can see this actor has several components within it
Implements its own behavior. So it is not just subject to the functionality of the components
It can have its own data and functions
So just here what I've said is that when this if we jump into this definition when this explosive barrel
Takes damage, then it causes it makes its explosion component explode
So what can I go into more detail about that in a second
But yeah, this is what and it just a really small example of what an actor might look like
We can also actually jump quickly into our engine to show a kind of useful
Flow for when thinking about putting things in C++ or blueprint and in our example scene, I've got here
We've got two of my amazing exploding barrel assets
And the way I've actually created this is we have this initial
Class here in C++. This is where we define kind of all the fundamental functionality
So we've said it has these components in it. It's got this data in it. It's got this functionality
We override this functionality from the base class
But once you're at the level of dealing with content and this will be dealt with in more detail in other sessions
But once you're at the level of dealing with content, it's kind of better to do that in blueprint
so what I've actually done here and this is a typical workflow is that I've done to find all the base behavior in C++ and
Then at the level that I've got something that's actually dealing with content like meshes and actual sound effects and things like that
I've made a blueprint that inherits from our exploding barrel class and I've made BP exploding barrel worth noting as well that
The BP underscore is just a typical naming convention
It is not hard coded as a requirement unlike the C++ A and U notation
And you can see here. I've just on the barrel mesh
I've just specified that it's going to have a cylinder mesh and it's using the default material and things like that
So this is a kind of typical workflow that you might have once you've got actors or really anything that's using content is
You have the base classes in C++ and you actually reference the content via a blueprint
Then that'll be explained more another time why that's particularly useful
And then finally our kind of last component
No pun intended of this workflow is the component itself
So when we talk about components
We're not talking about an ECS architecture for bringing all your data and having it together in one place for quick
referencing for your your CPU and that that's something distinct unreal does have an implementation for that called mass and
But we're talking about something slightly distinct that is more in common with the idea of entities and components in terms of other
engines such as unity
Where we have an odd an entity in this case the actor that represents the object in world
and components as
Interchangeable modular bits that can bring extra functionality
So yeah, they bring you reusable functionality and we can add them and remove them even at runtime
Components actor components are importantly called actor components because they rely on an actor to exist
We cannot have a component without an actor all components
Need to be attached to an actor and then they can reference that actor if required which will jump in
I'll give an example of that in a second
and the other thing is that
We have a availability to expose
functionality and expose
Variables just like on an actor to our blueprints mean that we can make as well as the components bringing this modularity
Inherently, we can also edit components in different situations to use the same component but provide different data to it
So if I were to give an example of what a component might look like is another example again using this same explosive barrel
The actual explosion that this barrel does is handled by a component and that means it's inherently reusable
So not only barrels can explode now and now I can put this explosion component on other things and
You can see we've used this explosion data asset here
and
our actual explode functionality is handed inside our component which basically just
Reads data from our explosion asset. It says, okay
Does it have a sound particle system then spawn that particle if it has a sound play that sound and then just do a little
World query to find all actors within the radius specified by the data again and
damage those actors and what that leads to is something vaguely explosion like where it damages
It does a particle does a sound effect and damages things in a radius, right and just to kind of demonstrate that behavior actually working
So I you don't need to worry about the actual blueprint functionality here
But just to quickly show what I'm doing when the level starts after a one second delay
I'm just damaging one of these barrels
but what you'll see is that because of the way the component works it damages everything around it and actually both of the barrels are going
To explode even though I'm only actually damaging one of them
So not exactly the most impressive sound effect not the best visuals, but I was just working with pre-made editor assets
But you can see then that that functionality clearly works. And what it means again is that we've got that added level of
Portability that you know, I've got explosive barrels now and now I can add that explosion functionality to grenades or whatever else that I want
The last component of this again, no pun intended
The last element of this is scene components, which we have already been demonstrating but not explicitly
Scene components are inherit from actor components
So they are actor components
But they're a very common and important distinction where scene components
Whereas raw actor components are there to provide functionality scene components exist within the world
And you can actually see this these two things are separated on an actor
And I'll just display that in a second actor components are maintained in a separate list to your scene components
And scene components provide anything that you would there would need some kind of world representation. So it can just be a location
It can be collision it can be visuals
scene components can also be attached to bones and sockets which makes them very useful for anything that needs to be
Relate to players something they might need to be holding like a knife mesh or something like that or a hat
Very very common one and yeah, they can also be used to detect collisions
So components can overlap with other components for any collision behavior that you need
Just to kind of quickly demonstrate some of the stuff I've been talking about
If we look here we'll see
We have a barrel mesh component. This is not a component that I've written myself
This is a static mesh component is a component that exists just in unreal by default
And you can see our actor has split these two sets of components up. We have my explosion component, which has no location data
It's kind of just abstract and it just provides the functionality of blowing up
And then we have our scene components which are maintained in this kind of hierarchy that will be similar maybe to any
DDC packages that you're used to working with where we have kind of a hierarchy
It's important to highlight that when we're dealing with scene components
At least at the blueprint level every actor must have at least one scene component
And it's that component that provides an actor with its location rotation
so when we have a
When we have when we ask an actor about its location and rotation
Actually, what we're doing is we're saying the location rotation of its scene of its root component a
Typical workflow might be that you have what's called a scene root, which is just a blank scene component with no extra data in it
It's basically just a position as an object's kind of pivot and then you attach other things to that
and that makes it very easy to do things like by default this barrel would actually be
Hit positioned here and then you would see all our barrels would be halfway through the floor
so we can use that scene root as a kind of
We can offset from that and because our mesh is a is a scene component itself. It has its own
Location rotation and scale so we can move it independently of this of this root component